знаменитому житла
росіян на резиденція президента
качай януковича та його артисту синю
у сотні мільйонів доларів після
відкриття роздягніть для грамот кістки
богачук затікала якіш залишки було у
президента який дозволяв subito курас
киш у 2014 роті
рахунки yanukovych а заморозила за
рішенням ради з позу в екс-президента
його сина Олександра рахунку скошування
санкцій розглянути 15 виріс над суді
євросоюзу з корми януковича може за
задоволені це поважаєте експерти натиснули
горах можна говорити про живиш залишається
біш reality czech елегантність в
україні уроки натуральне вирішено питання
по никах відпустку у 2014 роті рішення про
санкції про хвалила пастухом також
політики маглів стигнуть його і ви стоїть
за м'же is the hype тестову для санкцій
stable сдвиг прокурора української судді
євросоюзу виклик купити ставу не дасть від
її оджіно момент вид правління листа
тварин кримінальних справ чини була
сестра виживе крила це поки їх доведуть
до кінця продовжи вати санкцій з
цвинтаря видно чают експерти присутності
особистої клініки в судах то 32 точно
тільки нові банки для європейського
союзу що він та інше правильно так був
не правий . нам дала карт-бланш на морозі
факти мовити до наївності ви руки в
українці тут ще до рішення українців
філів зад ринку та розслідування в
q ризикуєте видами адвокати
самого януковича то його то дуже 15
виріс не інтереси української політики
вийти кочівники пара ховайся в Росії
представляє йому один із праведних
британських адвокатів
Томас бізлі послухай адвоката їсти
тисячі фунтів на води ну для оплати їх
yanukovych травня правого простого ти кішка
із заморожених ахун кіл їм підлога край
піднімаються з права проводяться
ґрунтування вічної процедури при наймі c
свічок від того ще на заходь з але і
правого тримала на відьому версії та й
іншим а то україни вдома на весну чи show
more
місяцями край 1 кукри морального затвора
нею раді що прямого впораєшся до
санкцій 2014 року за завданнями по суті
нічого не дати анджей сьогодні в ідея
список з анти з відкинуті у 2016 уроки
про ти його фігуранти списку то кішку
дав і поза ви батьки що означає ринковий
тяганина може роботою сивів